i feel like looking back on the movie
too for you especially um you know
people associate with you with the
character of sam but how do you feel
about him now at this point in your life
as opposed to maybe when you were
playing him for the first time has your
perspective on the character changed
um in the time since then my depth of
understanding him changes all the time i
mean just in this
series of interviews i've been doing i
talked to one person we were talking
about the fact that sam is a ring bearer
and when she lob stabs frodo
uh
and sam thinks he's dead sam takes the
ring and then he goes he realizes
frodo's not dead he goes up to the tower
of kirathungle he kills shagrat and then
frodo wants the ring back what is today
are we on is it monday what is today
monday so yesterday 20 years and a day
after the movie was realized it's the
first time that it occurred to me that
he
he didn't put the ring on
sam unless he did did he put it on to
hide from the from the orcs i don't
think he did
i see okay so here's what's happening so
fable.com
is a new uh platform that has book clubs
and i have a book club we just finished
my first one which is aldous huxley's
brave new world we're gonna
the publisher of lord of the rings
granted us the right to use it like just
a week ago so we switched from the book
i was gonna do to lord of the rings so
uh i'll let you know and we're gonna do
like a chapter week we started yesterday
it's an amazing thing i made a
determination with the re with the the
members of the book club to try and
experience it to the best i can
not from sam's point of view
everything
from the minute i bought the books the
first time from the minute i heard i
didn't even know what lord of the rings
was when my agent called me and would
have been late spring of 99 right she's
like it's lord of the rings trilogy i'm
like what's that she goes the hobbit
it's the hobbit i'm like what
so uh that's bad
but but i went to the bookstore and i
went in there and but she said i was
gonna audition for sam so from the
second i heard of the existence of these
things i heard of the the name lord of
the rings and the character of sam so
everything i've experienced of lord of
the rings has been from sam's point of
view so um
so i feel like i could do a dissertation
or maybe i have on sam
but in terms of perspective about him
and he's so reliable
he's so reliable in his in his ethic
his in his choices the choices of master
samwise um but just as a literary
character
he's such a reliable literary character
it's reliable that he's a devoted friend
it never is compromised so the story
takes you in all these different places
and all these different conflicts and
all these but the one thing that you can
can go back to and can have faith in is
that at least there's this at least
there's sam by your side all the time
you know so and it's it's just one
one thread of many to focus on but uh so
i don't think my perspective on that has
changed i think the older what i keep
saying to be i'm 50 years old now i'm a
50 year old man
you know i come to these books now as a
different
entity i've done i've done a lot of
different i have three kids now they're
all you know the youngest one's about to
finish high school
so
i wonder
as i come into this how i'll experience
sam differently this time from before
but one thing i
is immutable it's just that his
faithfulness
you know that that fidelity is is um we
need it so much in this world you need
it or else
there's just chaos
so um
you know
so it's an amazing thing that tolkien
created this character that can provide
that to us
you know i'm glad you brought the book
club because that was actually going to
be my next question which is first of
all you already answered this when you
first read the books but also what do
you enjoy about getting to kind of do
this this buddy read uh with the fans
officially okay so i tell people that
the first the i read it three times
while we were making the films but it
was more like um
you know in a i was
being in a cockpit of a of a plane that
was the engines had just gone out and
you're like looking at your checklist
you're like just reading through it
trying to find like what's the little
piece of information that i need to know
in order to get the engine to start back
up that's what that it was like data
mining i was like hard charging into the
book so i could appreciate the
literature i could appreciate the the
descriptions of the of the topography
and and all that but i didn't enjoy
those the books in the way that fans for
20 years have been describing to me how
they enjoy the books so now even that
creates its own sense of pressure about
my relationship to books about any of
our relationship to the books who worked
on the films so
my commitment
is to just try and let that go you know
we're reading it in
the plan is to read it in bite-sized
chunks i mean i know people who read the
book every year
and it takes them two days
they go into you know they go into the
room they close the door and they come
out two days later with tears streaked
on their face feeling like they're
recharged for the next year you know i i
can't do that this the reading's too
dense the ideas are too kind of
evocative and provocative and so so to
me i just want to take each of these
chapters i think we're doing like one a
week or something
and just tune out like turn off the
alerts on my phone
to i'm in i'm i'm in a graduate school
at the moment i just took my final
yesterday of a managerial economic class
i just took i passed it barely um i know
you're wondering so uh so but i'm on the
plane and i'm like okay how can i
decompress from that what what's the
trick of the mind that allows you to
like totally focus on what you're doing
so that you can be completely relaxed
while you're doing it
and that's it's like golf i don't know
if you ever played golf but golf you
have to be you have to be focused and
relaxed at the same time and so i'm i'm
hoping and it worked i mean what i was
what i came away with from the first
like
six or seven pages on the plane last
night was like just this
this light tone about these you know
it's concerning hobbits they're these
lovely
it's this lovely pastoral land and
they're fat and they're happy and
whatever and in a weird way you're like
it can't last
it wouldn't be a good book if it lasted
but you you
so
like i'm wanting to meet the book where
the books wanting me to be
the book wants me to know that there's
to have anticipation for what's coming
next
so i'm i'm wanting to like calibrate
that i don't know it's it's going to be
it it's going to be an amazing new
experience and what i've been saying is
you know the movies are 20 years old
you've got this dvd set now the 31 dvds
ultimate collection uh it's the super
ultimate mondo you got to be kidding me
this is ridiculous i didn't know that
there was so much love in the world
collection of lord of the rings
but for me like nothing can take away
the movies
nothing can take away
the 20 years of fandom that's come at me
all the conventions and autographs and
interviews and the award shows and the
and the everything that's gone into it
it's defined my whole
life from my 30s to my 50s it's nothing
can ever take out to read the books
without pressure i can afford without
the pressure of my career and what's the
impact going to be on my career what are
my agents going to think all that stuff
that operates in this in the in your
neurology
when i was making my bones so to speak
and as my acting career but now my
acting career is going to go where it's
going to go i'm going to it's going to
i'll continue to work i'm not worried
that i'm not when i finished lord of the
rings i was like what if i never work
again
you know
peter jackson teased me at one point i'm
like i'm like peter you know because
we're playing these little hobbits and
it's cute and it's funny and it's sweet
but in a way you're like we're
diminutive
you know and in a way that it's charming
it's also can be kind of pejorative
you know we have these doubles that
we're filming bk was my double he's
three feet tall he's 30 year old man you
know but you can't help but be like oh
bk he's a 30 year old man
you know and he was patient with all of
us and we we developed a level of
mostly because he would beat me at chess
and like have more knowledge in our you
know geopolitical discussions than i did
and i was always learning from it but
that aside so but i just remember like
having a moment of concern
and peter's like you mean you think
you're gonna walk into an audition two
years from now and they're gonna be like
oh we thought you were gonna be like a
little guy
and uh and i you know and i'm like yeah
i come to think of it but that's like
that's all behind me now
and now i can you know
i give talks about mental health all
over the country you know the country
was in a mental health crisis
particularly children
um
before the pandemic
and now we have the pandemic the sort of
soon to hopefully be post pandemic and
the
the damage that's been done to our
emotional and psychiatric and
psychological life won't be fully
understood for a decade
you know we we and it we try to ignore
it we're just moving past it everybody's
in their own thing but there's going to
be scholars there's going to be
you know tests done that through the
lens of history you'll look back at this
moment you'll go holy crap that was
that was an amazing thing that's like
you know
nothing like that had ever happened
where the entire planet shut down where
people were forced to stay away from
each other and the more you loved
someone the more you were
interested the more
intensely you wanted to stay away from
them in order to protect them that is a
psychological
thing so that that we that we don't know
how to deal with so these speeches that
samwise gets to give there's some good
left in this world and it's worth even
darkness must pass and a new day will
come and when the sun shines it'll shine
out the clear like there are things that
tolkien put in here
that are the result of a lifetime of
high quality intellectual focus
and spiritual focus
forged in the fires of the the first
world war and as a parent of someone in
the second world war and it's here it's
right in this little book
and so if we can if i can i'm using i
told them this yesterday in our zoom
kickoff meeting i'm using the the
members of the fan of the of the
book club
as a
tether and they're using me as a pace
car
and together i'm hoping you know people
you just sit and read the book yes oh
it's great it's so much more than that
there's no way that the tens of
thousands of people who i have
personally met over 20 years
who have tattooed themselves into
oblivion with lord of the rings
language and mythology and imagery
imagery you know from the movies our
faces tattooed on their bodies you know
doctors and lawyers and plumbers and
homeless people people who've wanted to
commit suicide and look to the books to
stop them from look to the movies those
movies saved me i was in traction for
two years after an accident i was you
know these they're bigger than movies
they're bigger than books
so
this is my little game
my little game it's not a game well it's
a gambit
is to say
i'm gonna i don't know it's just like
it's
i don't know what to say
well and i and i you know i
unfortunately i have to i have to let
you go but i will say just as a fellow
fantasy fan i think there's something
then what you're doing that is providing
a sense of community with bringing
people together to read this book and i
really hope that you on a personal level
are able to just enjoy the story so it
sounds like it sounds like that's what
you're you're aiming to do so i
wish you the best of luck with that and
thank you so much for said that
perfectly
you said that perfectly that's exactly
what's afoot thank you carly thank you
for uh for your
yeah for your elan thank you thank you
and and
congratulations again on the movie on
the book club everything and and best of
luck to you moving forward um and i hope
you have a great rest of your day you
too carly be well thank you so much
thank you
you